this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you so much for coming out
and it's really a pleasure to be back
here at Cornell and I'm presenting on a
topic that's really special to me so
I'll start off with just an introduction
to why why this topic is important and
and then some of the research that I did
for my thesis and then Don will give you
an overview of what's happening here at
Cornell with an exciting new initiative
for me the topic of how nature effects
well-being started more in the arts than
it did in the sciences I I studied art
history for in a while and I've always
loved this painting by Van Gogh and he
wrote in a letter to his brother how
much looking at nature was a comfort to
him in his final years when he was
confined to an asylum he continued to
paint and it was really the connection
to for his sanity but while he was
painting was nature and this beautiful
picture came out in one of the last
years of his life I also literature I've
The Secret Garden was one of my favorite
books and I really delved into it a few
years ago and I again the theme of how
working in a garden restores well-being
is as very powerful in that story and
then of course Cornell this is a picture
of the 80 White House gardens and that
among all the other gardens and Cornell
plantations there's just so much beauty
on this campus and not only as a grad
student but as an undergrad I found so
much solace finding these places and
little places to hide away and get away
from the pressures of academic life
okay so there's really three core issues
at the heart of my research first the
statistics for mental health among
college age students are very shocking
there are 57% who feel overwhelming
anxiety and also thirty-five percent who
have felt so depressed that it was
difficult to function I found that
statistic very very troubling so some of
these numbers are really high and here
are some numbers for what causes the
most stress academics being the top but
a whole bunch of other issues as well
but it's definitely a problem among
students so one in three really has
faces of some kind of mental health
issue in addition to all the
overwhelming stress of being a student
so that is another number that is really
amazing to me the other issue for me was
public gardens at colleges and
universities there a specific kind of
public art and they work with the
university by having a mission that
coincides with out of the University and
they are often fighting for their
existence trying to show that they're
relevant to the University and often
that leads to some issues there was an
article that it was discussed that why
should these resources be going to this
organization within the university that
maybe is not always clearly academic so
the issue of relevance
is a key part of the equation and then
finally the literature on these subjects
there's certainly a broad amount of
literature on nature and well-being and
and also within each of the areas of
health and with mental health and and in
colleges and universities but where they
intersect it's not as much and it's
certainly not as much when you get into
the study of public gardens particularly
there are many of these Guardians at
your colleges and universities and yet
they're not really being thought of in
terms of how are they helping students
beyond the academic part of their lives
so I'm just arguing the public gardens
are they very well could hold the keys
to a rejuvenation of student well-being
on these campuses and what I wanted to
try to answer was whether psychological
well-being whether it's a priority at
college and university gardens and
whether they can do a better job that
appropriating that role so before I get
into the more research part of I had to
really big into literature and I just
want to give an overview of the way I
thought of this was kind of going from
abroad amount of literature down to a
point starting off with the the breadth
of literature on nature and well-being
but then going down and getting closer
to the college and university experience
so just so okay so these are some of the
key thinkers that I wanted to introduce
to you Alaric who wrote an essay on the
power of a view through Hospital windows
that patients actually had
a very a better chance of recovery and
reaction to pain medications and also
fewer negative comments from from nurses
for when they actually had a view of
nature as opposed to a brick wall
another set of authors the kaplans wrote
about particularly this concept of
restorative environments and it's based
on this notion that there is attention
directed attention which is a voluntary
type of attention and it requires effort
and when that becomes fatigued that is
the the core of the problem is directed
attention fatigue and environments
natural environments particularly have
been known to soothe this actually
restore directed attention fatigue for
different reasons but particularly
because often they create a feeling of
being away setting up being set apart
they have a feeling of an extent of
space they create fascination and all
these features contribute to an
environment being restorative and are
these authors actually right here at
Cornell did a really neat essay about
school children and how access to nature
really worked as a buffer for stress so
they have their concept of nearby Nature
the value of having it close by it was a
function of how well these students
responded and
how they it reduced their amount of
stress Richard Louv his classic concept
of nature deficit disorder kind of close
to a attention deficit disorder or other
mental disorders but he puts this in the
mix and says that there is a lack of
interaction with nature among children
and he recommends vitamin n for vitamin
nature and then the question of the dose
of nature how much is enough there was a
study that was done that said that even
a minimal amount of of exposure to
nature and activity in nature just five
minutes was considered the most
effective of any of the other amounts
that were experimented with so a small
amount of time also low intensity was
found to be an effective effective and
also the difference in environments
between urban and more natural it didn't
seem to make a difference they were all
helpful as long as they had some kind of
green element ok so now going just from
that broad amount of literature that's
those are just samples with mental
health literature of common themes are
that disorders appear in the first three
decades of life and because these are
the ages that are college students this
is there's a high percentage on these
campuses of students who suffer with
these illnesses and then other there's
so many other factors that affect mental
well-being as well and all of them are
are certainly represented on a diverse
campuses the one that I found
interesting was the issue of help
seeking is a
it's something that students are
notorious for not reaching out for help
and often treatment is delayed because
of that and so it's a challenge that
needs to be considered in looking for a
way into how I was going to approach
public gardens with this topic I I
looked for other studies that were done
on campuses and there were a few
University of Massachusetts Amherst they
tried a horticultural therapy
intervention students went in and
interacted with plants they did
different techniques with a
horticultural therapist and then took a
survey and found that there are some
glitches in the study but predominantly
it was showing how stress was
significantly relieved by this
experience at this university in Hong
Kong views of green spaces and also just
the use patterns of different green
spaces were analyzed and recommendations
were made based on those results and
this university in England also was
interesting because it it looked at
different spaces on campus and found
that certain spaces closer to the
buildings usually more formal
environments we're really much more
preferred than then further away
sometimes more wild or natural
environments and also that as though
many students knew about these spaces
only about fifty percent really use them
and then getting into gardens or the
sort of a subset of nature Why What what
is special about the garden particularly
and often gardens are described as a
series of
rooms and there's a feeling of escape or
getting away that they promote there was
an article done and for the Public
Garden magazine that talked about how
gardens are this refuge from our
difficult time that we live in with so
much information and technology and and
access to problems worldwide and that
the garden is a safe place and this was
after 911 this statement was made saying
that at the Brooklyn Botanic Garden
there had never been such an overflow of
people who just needed that fart and
right after that devastating day so how
they open their doors to people and
people really needed that space and then
when in discussing gardens there's also
a some literature about why we prefer
gardens and for some it's goes back to
an evolutionary perspective of that we
were designed to our program to really
want to be in an environment that feels
safe usually an open one with trees and
it it takes away from the from the
stress of that fight-or-flight response
the other view is especially over most
of history was just the creation view of
the story the history of the Garden of
Eden and just that we were made for
gardens we were made to be gardeners and
a man named Benjamin Rush who was one of
our founding fathers and a physician and
psycho really psychiatrist he wrote
about gardening as an effective means
for treating mentally ill on his day
and horticultural therapy actually owes
owes its creation to to Benjamin Rush
University gardens have a history of
their own they really developed in about
the 13th century in England Oxford and
Cambridge were the result of monasteries
and that dissolved and they had cloister
gardens these spaces that were very
private and meant to be places of
healing and escape for people and these
became places of institutions of
learning and then later on in Europe and
especially Italy in the 16th century
gardens at university started to become
more incorporated into the intellectual
life of the University they became great
collections and they were studied for
their plants for their medicinal
qualities and so the concept of the
garden as a living classroom really
started to develop and I think is what
is predominant today and this is our
lovely Cornell plantations and just had
to get that in there my study had two
parts I did a series of interviews with
nine public gardens at colleges and
universities and I wanted to ask a
variety of questions these are the
institutions so Arnold at Harvard Smith
College Cornell of course Garvin is a
beautiful garden that's 175 miles apart
from its campus in Arkansas and just
being another an interesting insight
into its challenges that it has in
reaching students ralston in North
Carolina Maasai
university of michigan morris arboretum
university pennsylvania Scott Arboretum
that swathmore and UC Davis it was a
broad different kinds of gardens so it
gave me a lot of different perspectives
key to what I was looking for from these
gardens with the mission that not only
the mission of the garden but of the
university and how they pour
complemented each other so this
quotation is one that is often that was
posed to public gardens of saying to
stay relevant be sure that your mission
is in the vein of the mission of your
overarching organization the University
and then this is another thought that
came out of these interviews was the
concern about being not academic enough
some one at least one garden voice this
concern that it wasn't it was afraid of
not of embracing other types of
initiatives because it might not appear
in academic enough and that it was just
seen as a beautiful place which is an
interesting way of looking at it that
it's somehow bad but so this is
something I wanted to think about more
throughout the process
my questions were very basic questions
about just access to the garden and how
they market themselves but also more
questions related to well-being how its
stated in mission statements what types
of spaces they offer if they have any
involvement with health services those
kinds of questions and so a large area
of what i was looking at were statements
of mission and vision and i just put up
cornell for instance just a couple
snippets that show how they're very much
related porn l with enhancing lives and
livelihoods of students and cornell corn
oil plantations with enhancing
collections for the enrichment of
students so there's definitely a an
interplay and i looked at the text of
these statements for all these these
gardens and their their universities and
looked for how they might introduce the
topic of well-being or reaching students
my observations from the from the
mission statement part of the research
was few had really direct references but
there were a couple that actually talked
about how gardens are how gardens and
how the university is reaching out to
benefit student wives and particularly
actually making reference to well-being
but those were few of otherwise there
was i believe there was more of a
perception that they were helping
helping students in this way but not so
much actually making this an explicit
mission i identify different types of
references that were indirect things
that referenced sustainability or other
aspects that gesture towards well-being
and there were many of these
and I saw them as opportunities for the
garden to embrace as ways of getting
into the topic of well-being and
promoting well-being when I looked at
when i asked the gardens for spaces that
they considered restorative and that
promoted this feeling of getting away
that was that i found in the literature
usually highly designed areas were
mentioned natural areas to a couple
times asian-themed gardens were
referenced as being considered
restorative and sometimes those that
were at a distance from the campus or
that contained a structure within it
were referenced as being considered
restorative so there's these are some
images from some of these Gardens
including plantations but also spaces
that have been considered by the people
that I spoke with as being restorative
in terms of programming five of the
gardens had programs that were about
addressing well-being often or most all
of them were an exercise program or more
physical health two of those Gardens had
programs specifically for student
well-being and plantations being one of
them and so I think there's definitely
something going on just hasn't actually
filtered down to students specifically
yet but there are some developments that
are happening the escape program at
morris arboretum this is an exciting one
to watch they have the issue of being
about 10 miles away from downtown
Philadelphia
campus so enticing students to get away
and to get away from the busy downtown
environment the morris arboretum has
really taken advantage of different
types of media to market to students
that this notion through the notion of
the skate and it's been very successful
and offering transportation particularly
but this has been a successful example
of trying to get students out in nature
and then with working together with
health services only a few or have had
active conversations again plantations
is in there and 22 of these gardens are
have had that relationship started as a
result of student suicides that was just
an interesting one to keep where of that
often these calamities actually promote
these conversations and would it be the
other way around that would that would
be really wonderful that they would be
approached before these types of events
happened I wanted to get a more narrow
or picture besides what was happening in
public gardens and across the board so I
had a ready sample here at Cornell and I
wanted to just get some student
perspectives as opposed to
administrators of public artists when I
was speaking with so I did a few surveys
of a variety of students I wanted to
compare two types of students ones that
are focused more on nature such as in
horticulture and then students who are
notoriously not focused on nature
engineering students and who actually
have a reputation at Cornell as being
the most rest of all students
I don't know that's drive so my survey
was just a simple paper survey with
asking a variety of questions about
their level of stress for for one thing
and what was interesting was the
horticulture students and engineers
although i had about some different
numbers of how many students i
interviewed the same percentages had a
high level of a frequent stress so that
it was basically proportional on the
kinds of stress that they were reporting
so most of them had several times a week
and then another large chunk was those
who said all the time and taken together
those are about seventy four percent and
it was equal to the engineers as well so
it that was interesting for me to find
and also I asked about coping strategies
eating more sleeping more as far as
activities involving nature going
outside spending time in nature these
activities tend to be more more likely
done by horticulture students as opposed
to the engineers I don't know why
horticulture students were two times
more likely to consume or drink drug and
that's a little troubling but but it's
also interesting that they were more
likely to spend time in nature the I the
notion of weather nature prescriptions I
asked students whether they would they
thought nature prescriptions such as
being prescribed to take a walk in
nature whether that would be an
effective treatment for stress and for
other illnesses and those who said that
it would be very effective
tended to rate the benefits of nature
and to well-being and also the value
that they placed on on green things on
campus they rated those areas the
highest those who rated the connection
between nature and well-being lower and
also who valued nature less actually
didn't did not like the idea of nature
prescriptions as much so there was a
connection there I asked about what
prevents you from spending more time
outside engineers were more likely in
certain areas not to know where places
were it wasn't what their friends were
doing and just a preference for being
indoors and then what I wanted to get
across here was that those who bent who
reported that nature was beneficial to
well-being and that campus green was
important to them hooray when they rated
it the highest they also that coincided
with the number of times that they visit
visited a public garden or Cornell
plantations in this case the ones who
voted who go to plantations everyday
they also valued nature the most and
then the ones who never or only once
once a year would go into any of the
areas of plantations they rated the
value of nature to well-being very low
or also the value of green and plants
was rated lower the fewer times that
they
would spend at plantations I wanted to
find out what might entice students to
come to plantations more and top being
more transportation being offered events
and activities Wi-Fi some were just you
just can't get to them so there and I at
the end i just had recommendations one
being that identifying making a case for
well-being and often getting it down in
writing is very helpful having it in a
mission and and if it's not trying to
see if you can get it in there because
it's something everybody can work from
trying to make a link between academic
performance and well-being might help
this cause be promoted more because
there is that concern of being relevant
and often for universities that the
academic achievement is is the top so
showing the connection between how well
being often and how nature experiences
can really boost your concentration and
your ability to perform that might be a
way for gardens to say look at us and
this is an important thing we can do for
the organization for the university not
only just being a garden but coming at
it with others such as health services
Don will be telling you about an
initiative here at Cornell that is doing
this very thing looking at the garden
and seeing what types of spaces it has
that could be considered restorative and
really marketing those two students
getting ideas from other gardens like
the escape program at Morris or just
taking a step there's a grassroots
organization called active minds that
was started at UPenn in the wake of a
student suicide and this group has just
grown and they do awareness and events
at universities and it would be
interesting to have maybe host one of
those events at a public garden and get
involved in that conversation and just
staying open minded as just as a way of
being a living classroom but also
promoting other other issues and student
well-being is a pretty important one so
I'm going to hand this over to Don who
will talk about nature RS Thank You
Erica and I'm really pleased to have
this opportunity to talk about an
initiative with which we've been
involved for a couple of years now in
fact it was a meeting of the land
subcommittee of the president's
sustainable campus committee where
Marion krassnia professor and natural
resources David cutter the university
landscape architect and I got together
on the side and we were collectively
bemoaning the fact that there were so
few efforts on campus to really
encourage students to spend time
outdoors and one of us and actually I'm
not even sure at this point who it was
had heard about an effort that a group
of progressive physicians in the
Washington DC area had started in
conjunction with the National Park
Service and that partnership led to
something called Nate
prescriptions in which these physicians
were for patients who were suffering
from anxiety or extreme stress or
obesity related issues they were
actually writing prescriptions for those
individuals to spend time out in the
local national parks the contribution by
the Park Service was to develop very
detailed descriptions of each of their
holdings in the greater DC area what
types of natural features were present
how difficult the paths were to walk on
how you can access them by car or public
transportation and this seemed to us
like a great model for transferring to
Cornell so it was at that point that we
started to organize a group of faculty
staff clinicians from gannett and
graduate and undergraduate students
under the theme of nature RX at Cornell
and as you can see our very simple goal
is to reduce stress and thereby increase
physical and mental health and students
through their engagement with nature and
hopefully through that engagement to
cultivate in students and increased
appreciation for nature so in the two
intervening years since we first created
this group we have achieved a number of
goals we've done a lot of research we've
discovered that there's a national group
that calls itself nature RX terra mater
and if you google nature RX you will see
that they have very very funny videos
that are intended for a youth audience
when you see something beautiful and all
you can think about is
Instagram filters you may need to spend
more time out in nature and both of the
videos that that group has developed
thus far are in that sort of
light-hearted vein but with a very
serious message that we all need to
spend more time out in nature so we feel
that in promoting nature to students we
need to focus on some easily graspable
benefits that the time in nature will
provide so we are talking about the need
to be active are you worried about
sluggishness time outdoors is one of the
best predictors of being physically
active which can help to maintain
healthy heart healthy weight get smarter
this is something that appeals to
students are you preparing for an exam
time that you spend in nature enhances
cognitive functioning and attention
sometimes time out in nature can be
better than an hour of cramming before a
prelim get engaged are you feeling
isolated which is as erica was
explaining a very common cause of stress
and anxiety among students so find a
walking running or hiking club research
suggests that nature is a social magnet
that draws people together and fosters
social interaction and get well and this
really is the essence of what we are
focusing on if you're feeling bad just
take a short daily walk to improve your
feeling of well-being so in what ways
are we carrying out this nature RX
approach one that was very interesting
and very successful this past fall is
that Sonya skelly led a first-year
student class called take it outside in
which each week
the student enrollees were led by a
different cornell expert to explore one
of cornell's magnificent natural areas
in a different way we've been working
for several months on a CU in nature app
and website and very recently we were
really gratified that the IT team at
student services has taken over the
further development of this app and
website and we're going to be very
actively and heavily promoting those and
I'll talk a bit more about that in a
moment something that we're quite
excited about is that in following up on
that Washington DC model the clinicians
at Cornell health what we have known as
Gannett in the past are now actually
writing paper prescriptions that they
hand out to students that say nature is
beneficial to you we want you to go out
in nature and then they can check boxes
once a week twice a week four times a
week and the clinicians at gannett are
very interested in conducting a study of
those students who have received these
prescriptions to see what impact it has
on them over time we are starting to
promote the benefits of time in nature
in the ways that I was just explaining
through various media you know I'm an
old faculty member so I don't really
know what students follow these days but
we've discovered there's something
called slope media which has both a
paper publication and an online
constantly changing website and blog so
we have an interview set up later this
week with one of the editors at slope
media we're also working with members of
the Student Assembly to get an article
in The Daily Sun one of the
the undergraduate students that Marcia
in chiefly worked with last fall did a
comprehensive study of every course
offered at Cornell to see which ones are
currently utilizing nature to enhance
their teaching which ones could benefit
from greater use of time outdoors and
which ones are never going to get
outside we are in early discussions with
faculty in the Department of
Communications about building a research
project around messaging of encouraging
students to spend time outdoors to see
how different forms of messaging
different messages themselves will have
impact and we have a meeting this coming
Saturday in which we've invited student
representatives from organizations
across campus to come together and to
advise us on how we can make the nature
rx efforts more effective more impactful
for all of them so one of the earliest
things that or earliest efforts in our
nature RX initiative was the development
of a campus map by David cutter our
University landscape architect in which
he pointed out some of excuse me some of
the key natural areas on campus like BB
Lake and both cascadilla and fall creek
gorges that was sort of the jumping-off
point for us to work with a graduate
student in information sciences to
develop an app called see you in nature
that includes many of the natural areas
that are managed by cornell plantations
as well as natural areas in the center
of campus like we stinky glen
Tiger Glen and as of last week the
Liberty High Bailey conservatory and
here you can see a couple of the pages
from that app and this IT specialist
from student services who I was
mentioning is now working on the further
development of that and a companion
website so the idea here is not to have
students be studying this app or website
on their iPhones while they're out in
nature but rather to have them become
familiar with the spectacular natural
sites that exists here at Cornell and to
learn how far it is from their dorm
there's going to be a new feature on the
website in which a user can say how far
am i from the closest natural area right
now and it will tell how many minutes
the walk is to that site and how to get
there an effort we were involved with
this past November with president Beth
Garrett who is in our thoughts was also
called take it outside and it was a walk
around BB lake and to the plantations
winter garden for students and members
of both the Cornell and local community
and through nature RX we anticipate
running more and more events like this
simple events to just get people out in
nature and to find how close and how
attractive and how enjoyable it is and
this is a shot from the take it outside
class now that Sonia skelly ran this
past fall here is another shot and one
of the things about getting out in
nature is that you need to do it in all
types of weather and as you can see the
students were going down the gorge with
Sarah Fiorello and
mostly prepared for that in terms of
their clothing so what I'd like to say
in wrapping this up is that we have
simultaneously both a very very highly
stressed and anxious student body and
the statistics that erica was sharing
earlier bear those out the counselors
from the caps program at cornell health
counseling and psychological services
indicate that between eighteen and
twenty percent of all undergraduates
seek their support each year that's an
enormous number so at the same time we
have this very stressed student body we
also have one of the most beautiful
campuses in the world I mean look at
this that's right next to the
engineering quad so we feel that we have
this incredible opportunity to use the
natural beauty of our campus of Cornell
plantations to entice students outside
and to contribute to their overall
well-being so thank you
any questions for Erica or myself as a
question so if the strip's created under
a natural environment would pursuing
nature still be a way to release or sex
life or except this makes might not be
familiar to horticulture students are
some actually working in the field are
quite simple in forest for a very little
kind of creative the stress that's a
great question and I think that time in
nature and have certain stresses
associated with it one has you point out
is if you're they're really doing work
in order to get that work completed and
be stressful another is that if you're
not certain of the rent that you're
following it's easy to become stressed
about finding your way back to the
starting point and I recall that when I
was in Costa Rica several years ago
there was a program to get kids from
within San Jose capital city who had
spent no time in
nature to just step into woods and that
in itself was very stressful for them
because it was such an unfamiliar
environment so just becoming familiar
and comfortable with nature is off in
the first step it is a matter of
mindfulness of what you're choosing to
focus on or near your attention off of
the research on to
go left
environment around you
taking a five minute break from data
it's just beautiful
I often thought that
k
but just go can't because i would say
walk in any
per person or any person business
identify everything
place yet in nature they shall not
what's safe
your environment is a proven so what do
you think about half maybe two corporate
you can
and fishing that was definitely the case
of one study was that the natural areas
the more wild areas were not approached
you have been afraid of
them are just didn't know about them and
they were trying to get the idea
computation of the answer
things were actually people took time to
describe these places
two actually
need more familiar they would be used
more and also in the survey that
students form they raise that concern
they would
or
many different tastes
taking that time too
and interpret what these places are
they're going to find
and also teaching them about nature
learning viable plan
our worries more you know the more you
see where you enjoy
yes yeah so it from your survey d is
pretty strong correlation
time spent outdoors appreciation the
picture is that causation all is it a
chicken egg thing my outdoors or the
other way around or
each other
question
i think what i was trying to at least
argue with
the more
if the love of nature can be established
that
as far as which cod which I don't know
sometimes for some it might be greater
knowledge and be more familiar with
something
creates that that love joined in her
major for others it might be that love
draws them to want to learn more about
it so I think it is
I don't believe
yes yes Geneva any questions al no okay
yeah we'll take one more question Phil
do you think the getting getting back to
the question than heating up in a Wilder
area might be stressful do you think
that that could be an example of how
important it is having smaller more
controlled gardens on campus could be
truly beneficial small garden where
you're not going to get lost a small
garden that is obviously man-made
construction close to more building what
still would have the benefit of being on
trees being around thanks for this 5-10
minutes absolutely and I think there
really isn't
was trying to show that it didn't matter
if it was urban nature or more girl
nature just any I'm free really was that
officials so taking any more bite-sized
pieces definitely places right around
building seemed to be very popular don't
you need to get to that
the ease of access that illusion back
yeah the death
these smaller spaces
cultivating
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu